Cześć, mam na imię Olivia Lanes. Witaj z powrotem w kursie Quantum Computing in Practice. To jest odcinek drugi: Quantum
circuits. Omówimy dziś kilka tematów, ale chcę, żebyś po tym wykładzie zapamiętał przede wszystkim trzy rzeczy. Po pierwsze, czym właściwie są komputery kwantowe IBM,
żebyś miał przynajmniej ogólny obraz tego, co robisz, wysyłając zadanie do jednego z nich przez
chmurę. Po drugie, czym jest qubit, czym są Primitives i jak możemy ich używać do tworzenia i wykonywania quantum circuits.
Omówimy też ogólnie różne typy dostępnych procesorów IBM Quantum i to, co je odróżnia od siebie. Po trzecie,
na koniec typowy przepływ pracy, który stosujemy, aby uruchamiać eksperymenty na dużą skalę. Obejmuje to wybór najlepszych Primitives
do swojego przypadku użycia, mapowanie problemu na quantum circuit oraz stosowanie tłumienia i łagodzenia błędów, co pozwala nam
wycisnąć z tych maszyn jak najwięcej. Jest tu dużo informacji, ale trzymaj się ze mną,
bo wkrótce złożymy to wszystko razem w kontekście prawdziwych przykładów. Najpierw porozmawiajmy krótko o qubitach i rzeczywistym sprzęcie kwantowym.
Jako eksperymentator mogę ci obiecać, że to fascynujące i naprawdę pomaga połączyć kropki, gdy
wizualizujesz, co naprawdę się dzieje, gdy zadania są wysyłane do komputera kwantowego przez chmurę. Procesory,
których będziemy używać, są zbudowane z nadprzewodzących qubitów transmon. Oto jak wygląda mały procesor kwantowy IBM.
Te małe kwadraty to właśnie qubity, jest ich łącznie pięć na tym chipie. Transmon
sam w sobie jest kondensatorem złożonym z dwóch płyt metalowych połączonych równolegle z nieliniowym induktorem zwanym
złączem Josephsona. Aby jednak zobaczyć złącze Josephsona, trzeba jeszcze bardziej przybliżyć widok. Powstaje ono z dwóch
nakładających się warstw nadprzewodzącego metalu, a miejscem ich zetknięcia jest właśnie złącze. Złącze Josephsona
to element, który może być użyty do stworzenia sztucznego atomu z wieloma poziomami energii. Izolujemy
dwa dolne poziomy energii jako stan naszego qubita. Kręte linie reprezentują mikrofalowe rezonatory,
w zasadzie dwuwymiarowe linie transmisyjne sprzężone z qubitem. Kiedy programujemy gate, odpowiada to wybraniu
precyzyjnie skalibrowanego impulsu mikrofalowego, a konkretna częstotliwość, amplituda, kształt i czas trwania tych impulsów sprawiają, że
qubit wykonuje określone rzeczy. Instrukcje dla impulsu mikrofalowego trafiają z twojego komputera do chmury, a
następnie są odczytywane i interpretowane przez elektronikę sterującą w temperaturze pokojowej, która bierze te instrukcje i fizycznie
generuje impulsy. Nazywamy je impulsami mikrofalowymi, ponieważ wszystkie mieszczą się w paśmie częstotliwości mikrofalowych,
czyli około 1 GHz. Po tym jak elektronika w temperaturze pokojowej wytworzy impulsy, przemieszczają się one przez kable
do rozcieńczalnika kriogenicznego, a finalnie do naszego chipa kwantowego. Sygnał wchodzi do rezonatorów przez
drut bondingowy na tych podkładkach, a następnie płynie wzdłuż linii transmisyjnej do naszych qubitów. Wiem, że to wszystko może być
trochę techniczne i te szczegóły nie są nam kluczowo potrzebne w dalszej pracy, ale mam nadzieję, że teraz
możesz sobie wyobrazić fizyczny system, z którym wszyscy za chwilę będziecie wchodzić w interakcję. Gdzie więc te komputery kwantowe
faktycznie istnieją? IBM posiada dziesiątki komputerów kwantowych na całym świecie i niedawno zmodernizowaliśmy naszą flotę do
stanu zawierającego wyłącznie procesory z ponad 100 qubitami. Jak wspomniałam w poprzedniej lekcji, niektóre z nich znajdują się w centrum danych IBM
Quantum w stanie Nowy Jork. Te systemy są udostępniane wszystkim przez chmurę, a niektóre
są dedykowanymi systemami na miejscu, kompletnie wyposażonymi w elektronikę, które obsługują naszych partnerów
w sieci IBM Quantum. Porozmawiajmy teraz o Qiskit — otwartym zestawie narzędzi programistycznych IBM
przeznaczonym do pracy z komputerami kwantowymi. Od teraz będę nazywać go Qiskit SDK. Jest też ekosystem Qiskit —
zbiór oprogramowania, samouczków i funkcji, które bazują na lub rozszerzają podstawowe funkcjonalności Qiskit, a także Qiskit
runtime, czyli usługa obliczeniowa i model programowania, który pozwala użytkownikom projektować i efektywnie
wykonywać kwantowe obciążenia robocze za pomocą Qiskit Primitives. Primitive to w zasadzie mały blok budulcowy,
którego możesz używać do projektowania większych circuits lub zadania. Dwa Primitives, które są dla nas najważniejsze, to
sampler i estimator, które omówimy bardziej szczegółowo za chwilę. Jeśli nie pobrałeś jeszcze i nie zainstalowałeś
Qiskit SDK, nie ma co czekać. Qiskit 1.0 został niedawno wydany i jest bardziej wydajny i
stabilny niż kiedykolwiek. Więc jeśli dopiero zaczynasz, trafiłeś w idealnym momencie. Dla tych,
którzy już znają Qiskit, będziecie musieli pobrać i ponownie zainstalować najnowszą wersję. Zalecamy użycie
pip do zainstalowania Qiskit i Qiskit runtime oraz uruchamianie ich przez notebook Jupyter w wybranej przeglądarce. Będziesz też potrzebować
zainstalować Jupyter notebook lub Jupyter lab, jeśli jeszcze tego nie zrobiłeś. Wszystkie te narzędzia są bezpłatne i możesz
uruchomić je na własnym komputerze bez żadnych kosztów. Pamiętaj, aby dodać Qiskit z opcją wizualizacji
zależności, aby działał z Jupyterem i pozwalał na tworzenie wykresów. Będziesz też potrzebować skonfigurować wirtualne środowisko Pythona i są
instrukcje, jak to zrobić, na stronie instalacji Qiskit, podlinkowanej tutaj. Gdy już zaznajomisz się z Qiskit i będziesz
gotowy uruchamiać zadania na prawdziwych komputerach kwantowych, będziesz musiał zarejestrować się na quantum.com i utworzyć token IBM Quantum
API. Jest też link do tego poniżej. Szczegółowy przewodnik po tym, jak to zrobić — postępuj zgodnie ze wszystkimi
instrukcjami na naszej stronie dokumentacji, jak wspomniałam, lub możesz obejrzeć filmik instalacyjny Coding with Qiskit tutaj,
oba są podlinkowane w opisie. Jesteśmy już prawie gotowi, by zacząć mówić o quantum
circuits. Ponieważ celem tego kursu jest nauczenie cię, jak skalować zadania do uruchamiania na ponad 100
qubitach, uważam, że najlepszą ścieżką naprzód jest najpierw rozważenie ogólnego przepływu pracy, który będziemy stosować. Najłatwiejszy sposób, by
zrozumieć typowy przepływ pracy w obliczeniach kwantowych, to Qiskit patterns. Qiskit patterns to koncepcyjny framework pozwalający użytkownikom uruchamiać kwantowe
obciążenia robocze poprzez implementację określonych kroków z modułowymi narzędziami. Pozwala to na wykonywanie zadań kwantowych przez
potężną heterogeniczną infrastrukturę obliczeniową. Kroki te mogą być wykonywane jako usługa i mogą
obejmować zarządzanie zasobami, co pozwala na płynne komponowanie nowych możliwości w miarę ich opracowywania. Oto
główne kroki, które doświadczeni użytkownicy Qiskit zapewne już znają. Pierwszym krokiem jest mapowanie. Ten krok
formalizuje to, jak bierzemy ogólny problem, który nas interesuje, i ustalamy, jak go przekształcić na postać zrozumiałą dla komputera kwantowego
w formie circuit. Następnie optymalizujemy. W tym kroku używamy Qiskit transpiler, aby rozmieścić i zmapować
circuit na rzeczywistym fizycznym sprzęcie kwantowym. Obejmuje to tłumaczenie poszczególnych quantum gates na sekwencje
WEBVTT
operacji wykonywanych na sprzęcie, a także optymalizację rozmieszczenia tych gates. Następnie
wykonujemy zadanie. Qiskit runtime Primitives zapewniają interfejs do sprzętu IBM Quantum, który pozwala na uruchomienie przetranspilowanego circuit.
Ten krok obejmuje też stosowanie technik tłumienia i łagodzenia błędów, które w dużej mierze mogą być odciążone od użytkownika. Na koniec wykonujemy postprocessing.
W tym kroku dane z samego procesora kwantowego są przetwarzane, dostarczając użytkownikowi użytecznych wyników dla pierwotnego problemu. W zasadzie ten krok
obejmuje wszelką dalszą analizę zebranych danych. Jesteśmy teraz gotowi omówić podstawę programów kwantowych,
czyli quantum circuits. Mam nadzieję, że jesteś już zaznajomiony z quantum circuits, ale jeśli nie, możesz najpierw sprawdzić lekcję
trzecią: Quantum circuits, która jest częścią kursu Understanding Quantum Information and Computation, podlinkowanego poniżej. Tutaj
damy jedynie krótkie przypomnienie. Quantum circuit to sieć quantum gates i pomiarów połączonych
przewodami reprezentującymi qubity. Quantum circuits można czytać jak zapis nutowy od lewej do prawej, zaczynając od
czasu zerowego po lewej stronie. Wirtualne qubity, czyli qubity, którym nie przypisano jeszcze rzeczywistego
fizycznego qubita na procesorze, są wymienione w rosnącej kolejności od góry do dołu. Gdy skonfigurujemy nasz circuit, możemy dodawać do niego
gates. Jednoqubitowe gates, jak ten gate Hadamard, wpływają tylko na qubit, na którego przewodzie się znajdują. Wieloqubitowe
gates, jak CNOT, wpływają na dwa lub więcej qubitów połączonych przez gate. W tym przykładzie stan qubita numer jeden zmienia się
w zależności od stanu qubita zerowego. Po zastosowaniu wszystkich gates możemy przeprowadzić pomiary,
których wyniki są zapisywane na rejestrach klasycznych. Jedną ze szczególnie ważnych cech
circuit jest jej głębokość. Głębokość quantum circuit to minimalna liczba warstw quantum gates wykonywanych
równolegle, wymagana do zakończenia obliczeń zdefiniowanych przez circuit. Ważne: quantum gates mogą być wykonywane
równolegle, czyli jednocześnie, gdy nie mają żadnych wspólnych qubitów. Jeśli jednak dwa lub więcej
gates działają na tych samych qubitach, nie możemy ich wykonać równolegle — musimy wykonać je jeden po drugim. Ponieważ quantum gates zajmują czas,
głębokość circuit w przybliżeniu odpowiada ilości czasu potrzebnej komputerom kwantowym na jej wykonanie.
Znanie głębokości circuit jest więc ważne, by wiedzieć, czy można jej użyć na konkretnym urządzeniu. Powie nam też, czy ma
dobre szanse na dokładny wynik. Przejdźmy teraz do wyboru procesora kwantowego. IBM
niedawno wydał zupełnie nową flotę procesorów, wszystkie mające ponad 100 qubitów. Możesz zalogować się na quantum.com, aby zobaczyć,
do których procesorów masz dostęp. Procesory są wszystkie nazwane po ptakach z pewnych powodów, a różne loga
reprezentują różne typy procesorów. Na przykład te reprezentują procesory Eagle, a ta ikona to
Heron. Nazwy konkretnych procesorów znajdują się też na górze — wszystkie noszą nazwy miast, ale
nie oznacza to koniecznie, że procesor fizycznie znajduje się w tym mieście. To tylko nazwy. Liczba qubitów,
EPPG i CLOPS to czynniki, które są wymienione. Omówimy każdy z nich.
Qubity — to dość oczywiste. Qubits to po prostu całkowita liczba qubitów dostępnych do użycia na tym procesorze kwantowym, czyli
QPU. EPPG oznacza errors per layered gate i mierzy średni błąd procesu gate w ułożonej łańcuchowo warstwie
100 qubitów. W zasadzie chcesz, żeby był jak najmniejszy. CLOPS oznacza circuit layer operations per second i
mierzy, ile warstw kwantowego circuit woluminowego — będącego wirtualnym circuit — może wykonać QPU w jednostce czasu.
Im wyższa liczba, tym szybciej możemy obliczać. Odpowiada to temu, czym flopy są w klasycznych obliczeniach. Te
różne metryki mogą być mniej lub bardziej ważne w zależności od konkretnego obszaru zastosowań, który cię interesuje. Porozmawiajmy teraz ogólnie
o mapowaniu na quantum circuits. Pierwszy krok to etap mapowania, który w zasadzie odpowiada na pytanie: jak
przetłumaczyć mój problem na quantum circuit, który może być uruchomiony na sprzęcie kwantowym? Nie ma wątpliwości:
mapowanie to trudny problem i aktywny obszar badań. Czasami samo wzięcie problemu obliczeniowego
i wymyślenie sekwencji quantum gates, które pomogą go rozwiązać, jest najtrudniejszą częścią. Nie ma niezawodnej
metody gwarantującej sukces, ale są zalecane wskazówki i przykłady problemów, które już wiemy, jak
mapować. Pierwsza wskazówka: pozwól klasycznym komputerom robić to, w czym są lepsze. Zadania
łatwe dla klasycznych komputerów prawdopodobnie nie skorzystają z komputera kwantowego. Komputery kwantowe są przeznaczone do problemów trudnych klasycznie.
Oczywiście, jeśli to twój pierwszy raz z Qiskit lub komputerem kwantowym, nie martw się o znalezienie problemu złożonego obliczeniowo. Rozbij go
na mniejsze problemy, których możesz się nauczyć rozwiązywać, zanim przejdziesz do projektu w skali użytkowej. Następnie przetłumacz
wyniki twojego problemu, które chcesz zmierzyć lub zrozumieć, na problem wartości oczekiwanej lub problem próbkowania.
Dla większości typów problemów odpowiada to w zasadzie obliczeniu funkcji kosztu. Funkcja kosztu to
specyficzna dla problemu funkcja, która definiuje cel problemu jako coś do minimalizacji lub maksymalizacji i może być
używana, by zobaczyć, jak dobrze stan próbny lub rozwiązanie sprawdza się w odniesieniu do tego celu.
Tę koncepcję można zastosować do różnych aplikacji w chemii, uczeniu maszynowym, finansach, optymalizacji i tak dalej.
Pamiętaj też, że sprzęt, którego będziesz używać, ma określoną topologię. Niektóre qubity nie są połączone,
a inne tak i ostatecznie będziesz musiał odwzorować swój problem na circuit reprezentujący tę topologię. Procesory IBM Quantum
używają tzw. topologii heavy hex, która w zasadzie odpowiada połączeniom qubitów w siatce heksagonalnej,
do czego wrócimy później w kursie. Na razie najważniejszą rzeczą do zapamiętania jest to, że ten etap wymaga
praktyki. Musisz dobrze rozumieć nie tylko swój problem, ale też możliwości sprzętu kwantowego,
a my przejdziemy przez konkretny przykład i przypadek użycia, by zobaczyć, jak można to najlepiej
zbalansować. Porozmawiajmy teraz o tym, jak optymalizować circuit dla wybranego sprzętu. Ogólnym celem
etapu optymalizacji jest odwzorowanie wszystkich wirtualnych qubitów z naszego circuit na rzeczywiste qubity gdzieś w
topologii procesora. Celem gry jest jak największa redukcja błędów. W tym celu musimy najpierw
efektywnie rozmieścić i trasować nasz circuit. Przede wszystkim pamiętaj, że nie wszystkie qubity są połączone,
jak już mówiłam — niektóre są od siebie odległe na chipie, więc musimy redukować lub eliminować długodystansowe
interakcje, gdy to możliwe. Możesz zastosować sekwencję swap gates między sąsiednimi qubitami, by przesuwać informację qubitową,
ale swap gates są kosztowne i podatne na błędy, więc mogą być lepsze sposoby. Następnie rozmieszczenie
WEBVTT
i routing to procesy iteracyjne – przypisują wirtualny qubit z twojego circuit do fizycznego qubitu na
sprzęcie. Możesz to zrobić ręcznie, ale w Qiskit są też narzędzia, które mogą rekomendować fizyczny
układ qubitów na podstawie przybliżonych współczynników błędów. Następnie możemy składać sekwencje bramek jednoqqubitowych działających na tym samym qubicie
w pojedyncze bramki i możemy też czasem pozbyć się niepotrzebnych bramek lub kombinacji bramek. Na przykład
niektóre kombinacje bramek można sprowadzić do prostszych kombinacji, a czasem kombinacje bramek nawet
odpowiadają po prostu prostemu operatorowi identyczności, więc możemy je po prostu wyeliminować. Możesz to zrobić automatycznie używając Qiskit
transpiler lub ręcznie, bramka po bramce, jeśli masz dobry powód, żeby to zrobić i chcesz
mieć większą kontrolę. Gdy już poprawiliśmy układ, routing i liczbę bramek w circuit, ręcznie lub za pomocą Qiskit transpiler,
zazwyczaj chcemy zwizualizować nasz circuit, żeby upewnić się, że timing wszystkich bramek ma sens. Jest argument, który możesz flagnąć w transpiler, żeby
zwizualizować harmonogram czasowy twojego circuit i upewnić się, że wszystko jest wyrównane tak, jak byś oczekiwał. Porozmawiajmy teraz o tłumieniu
błędów. Tłumienie błędów odnosi się do różnych technik, które przekształcają circuit podczas kompilacji, żeby zminimalizować błędy.
Różni się od mitygacji błędów, która ma miejsce po tym, jak circuit już został uruchomiony, i do tego wrócimy za chwilę. Dwie najczęstsze formy
tłumienia błędów, z których korzystamy, to dynamiczne odsprzęganie i twirling pauliewski. Będą tu
pewne szczegóły techniczne, ale zawsze możesz do tego wrócić później. Więc pierwsze – dynamiczne odsprzęganie – jest używane do
efektywnego cancelowania części szumu wpływającego na qubit poprzez stosowanie serii bramek, które razem dają
operację identyczności, jak sekwencje XX, i których łączny efekt to przybliżone cancelowanie kanałów szumu wpływających
na qubit. Twirling pauliewski to sposób na wstawianie losowych bramek w celu uproszczenia średniego szumu. Losowość pomaga
zapobiegać narastaniu efektów różnych błędów i sprawia, że szum jest łatwiejszy do scharakteryzowania.
Ta metoda stanowi też podstawę techniki mitygacji błędów i będziemy o tym rozmawiać później.
Znowu, jest tu dużo informacji i nie martw się, jeśli nie wszystko wsiąknie od razu. Na szczęście wiele z tego można zrobić automatycznie używając Qiskit
transpiler. Transpilacja może być trudna, ale jest tak kluczowym krokiem do osiągnięcia użyteczności w skali,
że wymaga dużo prób i błędów, żeby ją opanować i uzyskać najlepsze wyniki. Teraz chcę zrobić krótkie
odstępstwo, żeby nieco bardziej omówić Qiskit transpiler i jego możliwości. Zrobię to na bardzo wysokim poziomie i zajmiemy się szczegółami oraz zobaczymy
kilka przykładów później. Ogólnie transpilacja to proces przepisywania danego wejściowego circuit, żeby dopasować
topologię i specyficzne urządzenie kwantowe oraz zoptymalizować circuit pod kątem wykonania i odporności na szum. Przepisuje też
dany circuit do zestawu bramek bazowych tego konkretnego procesora kwantowego, który wybrałeś do użycia. Qiskit ma cztery
wbudowane pipeline'y transpilacji i jeśli nie jesteś już zaznajomiony z optymalizacją quantum circuit, zdecydowanie polecam używanie jednego z tych
wbudowanych pipeline'ów. Domyślnie transpiler zawiera te sześć kroków: inicjalizacja,
układ, routing, tłumaczenie, optymalizacja i harmonogramowanie. Inicjalizacja odnosi się do
każdego wstępnego przebiegu wymaganego przed zaczęciem osadzania circuit na backend. Zazwyczaj obejmuje to
rozwijanie niestandardowych instrukcji i konwertowanie circuit do samych jednoqqubitowych i dwuqubitowych bramek. Etap układu stosuje
mapowanie wirtualnych qubitów w circuit na fizyczne qubity na backend. Routing działa po zastosowaniu układu
i wstrzykuje bramki takie jak bramki swap do oryginalnego circuit, żeby był kompatybilny z połączalnością backend.
Czwarty etap to tłumaczenie. W tym etapie bramki w circuit są tłumaczone na docelowy
zestaw bazowy backend. Następnie jest optymalizacja – ten etap uruchamia główną pętlę optymalizacji
wielokrotnie, aż zostanie spełniony warunek, taki jak osiągnięcie pewnej docelowej głębokości. Mamy cztery różne poziomy optymalizacji,
z których możemy wybierać. Ostatnie jest harmonogramowanie – ten etap obejmuje wszelkie przejścia harmonogramowania z uwzględnieniem sprzętu. Na wysokim poziomie harmonogramowanie można rozumieć
jako wstawianie opóźnień do circuit, żeby uwzględnić czas bezczynności qubitów
między wykonaniem instrukcji. Więc jak mówiłem, są cztery poziomy optymalizacji od 0 do trzech, gdzie
wyższe poziomy optymalizacji zajmują więcej czasu i wysiłku obliczeniowego, ale możesz skończyć z lepszym circuit.
Poziom optymalizacji zero jest przeznaczony do eksperymentów charakteryzacji urządzenia i jako taki tylko mapuje wejściowy circuit na
ograniczenia docelowego backend – nie wykonuje żadnej optymalizacji. Poziom optymalizacji trzy
poświęca najwięcej wysiłku na optymalizację circuit. Jednak ponieważ wiele technik optymalizacji w
transpiler opiera się na heurystykach, większy wysiłek obliczeniowy nie zawsze przekłada się na poprawę
jakości wyjściowego circuit. Jeśli ten temat cię interesuje, sprawdź strony transpiler w dokumentacji Qiskit
podlinkowanej poniżej. Teraz jesteśmy gotowi omówić faktyczne wykonanie quantum circuit.
Qiskit Runtime Primitives zapewniają interfejs do sprzętu kwantowego IBM i abstrakcją oddzielają tłumienie
i mitygację błędów od użytkownika. Prymityw sampler zwraca rozkład quasi-prawdopodobieństwa lub zliczenia
reprezentujące prawdopodobieństwo zmierzenia pewnych ciągów bitów – zer i jedynek. Prymityw estimator zwraca wartości oczekiwane
obserwowalnych odpowiadających wielkościom fizycznym. Więc w nieco większym szczegółu: sampler uruchamia circuit
wielokrotnie na urządzeniu kwantowym, wykonując pomiary przy każdym uruchomieniu i konstruując rozkład
prawdopodobieństwa z odtworzonych ciągów bitów. Im więcej uruchomień, czyli shots, tym dokładniejsze będą wyniki,
ale wymaga to więcej czasu i zasobów kwantowych potrzebnych do tego uruchomienia. Konkretnie oblicza
prawdopodobieństwo uzyskania każdego możliwego stanu standardowej bazy, mierząc stan przygotowany przez circuit. Qiskit
estimator używa złożonego procesu algebraicznego do szacowania wartości oczekiwanej na prawdziwym urządzeniu kwantowym, rozkładając
obserwowalną na kombinację innych obserwowalnych, które mają znane bazy własne i uruchamiając. Pod maską
Primitives są techniki zwane mitygacją błędów. Mitygacja błędów to zbiorcze określenie na to wszystko i
w zasadzie odnosi się do technik, które pozwalają nam redukować błędy w circuit poprzez modelowanie szumu urządzenia w czasie
wykonania. Zazwyczaj skutkuje to narzutem kwantowego przetwarzania wstępnego związanym z treningiem modelu i klasycznym
narzutem przetwarzania końcowego, żeby mitygować błędy w surowych wynikach przy użyciu wygenerowanego modelu. Ale w zamian za ten
narzut jesteśmy w stanie uzyskać znacznie dokładniejsze wyniki. Istnieje wiele technik, które możemy wdrożyć dla
WEBVTT
mitygacji błędów i omówimy trzy z nich bardziej szczegółowo. Miej jednak świadomość, że jest to obszar
aktywnych badań, więc prawdopodobnie zostaną wynalezione nowe techniki, a starsze będą nadal ulepszane. Poziom
odporności zwiększa koszt, czyli innymi słowy czas potrzebny na uruchomienie zadania. Powiedzieliśmy już, że przy
poziomie odporności zero transpiler niewiele robi z twoim circuit, ale od poziomu odporności jeden wprowadza metodę zwaną twirled
readout error extinction, którą w skrócie nazywamy T-Rex. Twirled readout error extinction używa twirling pauliowskiego do
mitygacji szumu, o czym już wspomnieliśmy. To bardzo ogólna i skuteczna technika, która
intuicyjnie mówiąc sprawia, że szum jest mniej nieregularny i łatwiejszy do obsługi. Zaczynając od poziomu odporności dwa,
wprowadzamy ekstrapolację zerowego szumu, w skrócie ZNE. To popularna technika, z którą ostatnio mieliśmy dużo
sukcesów. Pomysł stojący za ZNE może być nieco zaskakujący – faktycznie dodajemy dodatkowy
szum do tego, który już istnieje, ale pozwala nam to ekstrapolować w odwrotnym kierunku, żeby
przewidzieć, jak wyglądałyby wyniki przy mniejszym szumie. Można to zrobić na kilka konkretnych sposobów – na przykład
możemy rozciągać bramki, żeby były dłuższe i tym samym bardziej podatne na błędy, albo możemy uruchamiać więcej bramek, które ostatecznie
dają operację identyczności, więc circuit funkcjonalnie się nie zmienia, ale celowo próbkujemy więcej
szumu. Musisz jednak to robić dla każdego circuit i każdej wartości oczekiwanej, którą chcesz śledzić, więc
widzisz, że może to być bardzo kosztowne pod względem wymaganego czasu. Jeden konkretny typ ZNE nazywa się
probabilistycznym wzmacnianiem błędów, w skrócie PEA. Po nauczeniu się modelu szumu dla bramki, PEA działa poprzez próbkowanie
błędów z tego modelu szumu i celowe wstrzykiwanie ich do circuit. Jak wspomniałem, wciąż
rozwijanych jest wiele nowych technik i mamy nadzieję, że będą wdrażane, gdy będziemy widzieć więcej z nich w użyciu. Jest jeszcze tylko jedna końcowa forma
mitygacji błędów, o której chcę powiedzieć – probabilistyczne cancelowanie błędów. Zamiast być na trzecim poziomie odporności,
PEC to specjalna możliwość, którą musisz ręcznie włączyć w Qiskit, ponieważ zasoby obliczeniowe
potrzebne do niej nie skalują się tak dobrze w porównaniu z innymi technikami mitygacji błędów, które omówiliśmy. Zaczynasz
od uczenia się o szumie wpływającym na twój circuit, uruchamiając uczenie szumu lub circuits charakteryzacji szumu
dla każdej unikalnej warstwy dwuqubitowych bramek w twoim circuit. Wyniki te pozwalają opisać szum
w kategoriach operatorów pauliowskich. Gdy już znasz te człony szumu, możesz modyfikować swoje circuits, żeby
skutecznie miały wbudowane odwrotne PEC do cancelowania tych kanałów szumu. Pod pewnymi względami ten proces jest
podobny do słuchawek z redukcją szumu. Jednak ten sposób cofania szumu jest bardzo kosztowny – czas
uruchomienia rośnie wykładniczo szybko wraz z liczbą bramek, więc może nie być najlepszym wyborem dla bardzo dużego circuit. Dotarliśmy
teraz do ostatniego etapu – przetwarzania końcowego. Jeśli wykonałeś dobrą robotę i zastosowałeś właściwe techniki
mitygacji błędów, możesz zobaczyć, że twoja końcowa odpowiedź przesuwa się, jak na tym rysunku tutaj. Niemitygowany rozkład
pokazany na fioletowo jest dość daleko od prawdziwej oczekiwanej wartości pokazanej tutaj przez tę linię. Jednak gdy zastosujemy naszą
mitygację błędów, dostajemy zmitigowany rozkład pokazany tutaj na niebiesko, który szczytuje znacznie bliżej prawdziwej wartości. Teraz
wszystko to ma pewien koszt i tutaj widzimy, że wariancja, czyli szerokość rozkładu, jest zwiększona, co
generalnie nie jest tym, czego chcesz, ale wszystko ma swoją cenę. Na szczęście możemy to uwzględnić, uruchamiając więcej
shots, co powoduje, że rozkład kurczy się z powrotem do akceptowalnego poziomu niepewności. I to mniej więcej tyle jeśli chodzi o tę
lekcję. Na następny raz weźmiemy wszystkie te kroki i połączymy je ze sobą oraz przejdziemy przez obszar i przykład
rzeczywistego zainteresowania aplikacyjnego. Jest kilka rzeczy, które polecam zrobić do tego czasu. Jeśli jeszcze tego nie zrobiłeś,
pobierz i skonfiguruj Qiskit 1.0. Możesz też sprawdzić powiązaną lekcję do tego rozdziału i
poprzedni odcinek na platformie IBM Quantum Learning. I na koniec, jeśli masz ochotę zagłębić się bardziej i
dowiedzieć się więcej o technikach mitygacji błędów, sprawdź jedno z licznych źródeł, które podlinkowałem poniżej. Do tego czasu do zobaczenia następnym razem.
[Muzyka]